I used to spend up to $500 a month on Cursor,
but the worst part wasn't the money.
It was the uncertainty because in some months,
I would barely hit the monthly limits
while other months I would watch my bill go up to $488.31.
So last week, I finally unsubscribed from Cursor
and started using Claude Code instead.
But Claude Code comes with its own set of problems.
And I really didn't like that it didn't have a file tree
to browse the project.
It didn't show me the changes that it made.
and that it had me locked into the clawed-only models
without access to models like GPT-5.
But then, just a few days after switching,
I found a tool that solved all of these problems and more.
And the best part was that it was free to use.
This tool is called Conductor.
And after testing tons of different options,
this one to me is the first one
that actually feels like a worthy competitor to Cursor.
So let me show you why.
Because let's start with the most obvious issue.
Cloud Code runs in the terminal.
And listen, I get it.
If you are technical, you might love it.
But most of my students are not
and they will find it genuinely scary.
But even if you do love the terminal,
you're still missing out on very important features
that will make you a dramatically better
no-code software architect.
And the biggest one is simply being able to see
what the AI is doing.
It's kind of like hiring a contractor
to renovate your house,
but they won't let you see the blueprints
or walk the job site.
You just have to come home one day, randomly,
after they finished and hope that they didn't accidentally
break anything that they weren't supposed to.
This is where a file tree lets you see exactly
what files AI creates.
So you start to understand what the app folder is,
where components should live,
how your project is structured, and most importantly,
you can verify that the AI actually did what you expected
without writing code.
You also need a way to see the changes that clawed code made
because this will give you the confidence
that it didn't touch a bunch of other files
that if it did would be a sign
that your prompt wasn't clear enough.
This is actually a key problem to look out for
and one that will help you avoid large changes
that you didn't ask for.
Because when you open Conductor,
it really feels like a proper editor without the code though.
You've got your file tree.
Let me just show it to you.
You got your file tree on the right, right here.
So you can click through the project where all the files are and even click on them to see what's in sight.
In rare cases where you do want to edit a specific file manually, you also have a button up here that will open this project in your favorite editor, which for me is still Cursor.
But you have a lot of them available.
You have like Cursor, VS Code, Zed, Windsurf, Ghosty Warp, right?
Even Anti-Gravity.
and you can even copy the path if you really want to.
You can also see all the files that changed,
which again, while you don't have to code,
you definitely have to understand what your project is doing
if you want to keep it scalable in the future.
So there is also a run button down here
that will automatically start your development server
and even a review button that will run a full code review
all without running any commands manually
or asking a terminal version of Claude anything.
And while all of these differences might sound small,
I guarantee that they will make you faster
and more confident in building with AI
while again, never writing code.
But it's great to have a pretty interface,
but what really makes Conductor powerful
is how it handles the scariest part of AI coding.
Because here's the moment that every AI coder knows.
You ask the model to rebuild this function
or fix this bug when clicking this and this button.
Then it goes away and after a few minutes it says done,
but suddenly half of your app is literally broken.
Now you're spending the next two hours undoing damage
instead of building something new.
You're digging through your history,
trying to figure out where it went wrong
before ultimately accepting that the working version
that you used to have is gone forever.
This is the problem that GitHub branches and work trees,
two very important words that you need to remember
if you don't know them yet, they solve this
because they kind of work like Google Docs version history.
You can see every change that was ever made
roll back to any past point in time
and nothing is ever truly lost.
And a branch is sort of the same concept,
but for your entire code base.
It's a parallel copy
where you can break things without consequences.
And then work trees take branches one step further
by creating a completely isolated copy,
which means that you can have multiple agents
working in isolated copies of the same project
at the same time without these agents fighting each other
or getting confused about code
that they didn't write or edit.
And the best part of all of this is that
you truly don't need to understand how any of this works
because Conductor abstracts this functionality away
with something that they call WorkSpaces,
which automatically create a new branch
and a work tree for you.
This means that you can literally go wild.
You can delete files.
You can do all types of things.
All you have to do is click.
So once you have all the projects here,
you can just click new workspace
and then Conductor will set this up for you, right?
So you see now I have a completely isolated copy
of the same project.
And here I can do all types of things.
I could like delete files if I wanted to
and do all types of like crazy stuff.
And then if it works, great,
because we can get these changes back
into your main project in just a moment.
But here's the thing.
If it breaks, you can literally just archive
this broken workspace and your main project,
let me just do this right now,
never knew that these changes even happened.
It's like you never broke anything to begin with.
But now the question is,
when you have built something great in your safe workspace,
how does it actually get back into your main project?
This is where a lot of people will get lost
in these GitHub terminologies
because there's branches and merges and rebases
and it all sounds very complicated.
But the concept is actually really simple.
Let's go back to this like Google Docs analogy
because imagine you have a contract
that needs to be signed
and you have made edits to this contract
and now you need to send it back to the other party
for them to check.
So you say, here's what I changed,
please review it before we both sign this contract.
With GitHub, this is called a pull request
and it's essentially a formal,
listen, here are my changes,
Let's review all of them before merging them back into the main project.
And in Conductor, you can literally just press a single button to do this.
So all you have to do is literally go up here and click the PR button, right?
Create PR.
And then what it does is it opens a pull request on your behalf on GitHub.
You can see this right here.
There's actually a custom prompt that it will inject into the current chat.
So you don't have to explain anything.
And then before you know it, it will actually create this pull request for you.
And you can see this right here.
Perfect.
Let me create the PR right now, creating the pull request on GitHub.
It runs all of these commands completely for you.
And then before you know it, the button up here has turned into PR33, which means in my case, this is the 33rd pull request that I have opened in this particular project.
And you can actually click this button again and then open it inside of GitHub.
And then on this page, it can actually show you exactly what changed as a text summary and what
files changed and how many lines have changed. So for example, here you can see that 55 lines have
been added, 39 lines have been removed. So it's a relatively small change. Three files have changed.
You can actually see which files changed, but again, it would require you to, you know, like
read code. You don't really want that, but at least you can see that only three files were changed,
which is great, right? You can see that there was one commit, which hopefully you already know what
that is, and you can see the entire conversation. But here's the thing. You have made some changes,
you have created the pull request, but how do you actually know if you're not a developer,
if these changes are safe to merge into the main project? This is where AI code reviewers come in.
So tools like Cursors, BugBot, AugmentCodes, CodeReview, CodeRabbit, CodeXReview, Graptile,
they all come into play at this very stage during a pull request and then automatically analyze
your changes. If they find problems, you can literally just copy their feedback back into
Conductor and make fixes. And then Conductor will automatically update this pull request,
and then reviewers can run again and you can keep this loop going back and forth until you are
confident that the changes you made are actually safe. This is actually the workflow that real
engineers use every day. And in this particular case, I've actually introduced a bunch of errors
into this project so you can see what this looks like. So you can see here I have the
greptile code reviewer running. And it's funny, this pull request intentionally introduces multiple
critical security vulnerabilities and removes essential protections for demonstration purposes.
Yeah, exactly. So you can see that it found like all types of things here. It has a confidence score
of zero from five important files have changed, right?
And there's a bunch of different problems.
Like here, there's a fake API key that I introduced,
or there's some like logging,
like remove before production, right?
So it picked up on all of these changes.
And if I wanted to,
I could literally just copy these, for example, right?
And be like, okay, wow.
Like prompt to fix this,
Graptile in particular gives you a prompt to fix this,
which you could just like copy.
and then do just copy it back in here and then go through the loop as explained.
And this entire workflow is made so easy by Conductor that it becomes a no-brainer to use.
But there's one big problem, a limitation that Claude code on its own can't fix.
Because when you use only Claude code directly, you're locked into the Claude models,
which means Haiku, Sonnet and Opus. That's your entire menu.
And listen, before you start commenting down below that Opus is like Alien Tech and the best model,
It's not. It's a really great model at generating code and iterative sort of like coding together
with you. But GPT-5, it's actually better at a lot of tasks like code reviews, bug fixes,
and creating large architectural plans. It's also better at working on its own for hours,
if you know what you're doing. I personally use GPT-5 High whenever I build something high stakes,
like a payment integration or large architectural changes, maybe a big API integration, something
like that, right? And just a while back, I built out a Stripe webhook and payment flow using GPT-5
Codex High. It took easily 40 minutes, right? Like way longer than Opus would have, but it just
knocked it out of the park while I was working on another thing. It just ran on its own, tested
everything, and then delivered something that worked right away. Then I used the standard GPT-5
to review everything because just to get this out of the way, Codex is really great at autonomous
work and the standard vanilla GPT-5 variants, they are much better at detailed analysis,
reviewing that type of stuff. So I often use GPT-5 to review everything that Opus, for example,
builds. And typically there are things that GPT-5 will find that Opus messed up. Sometimes it's just
duplicated code or things that it didn't consider, but other times it's actually critical bugs that
Opus just couldn't catch. And if you just use cloud code on its own, there's just no way for
you to tap into the benefits of both of these worlds. But in Conductor, you have full access
to both. You're literally one click away to switch from Opus 4.5 to GPT 5.2. This is what the best
AI builders do today, because when you have access to both, you get the incredible power of Opus 4.5,
which is a really great model with the confidence and better thinking capabilities of GPT 5.
Use Claude for fast building and everyday tasks and then switch to GPT-5 for deep reviews,
larger plans, because it's just better at it.
And because you're no longer locked into one of these model families, you get both.
But it gets even better, because just like a cursor, you don't have to choose one model
at a time.
Because AI coding happens usually one thing at a time.
You prompt, you wait, you review, you prompt again, always waiting for the last thing to
finish before you start the next. But what if you didn't have to wait? What if you could have one
agent build a feature while another answers a question about your code base or updates some
documentation that is due? I do this constantly. I have one tab for example where Opus is building a
new feature or a new dashboard. I have a second tab open where I ask with Sonnet because it's a bit
cheaper to answer questions about an API while I'm planning a next feature or something like that.
And then sometimes if I'm going wild, because you know, like some models, they are like slower than
others, I have a third tab open where for example use GPT-5-high to update documentation or plan
something because all of these can do work independently at the same time. But in Cloud
Code, you would literally need to have multiple terminal windows open, you would have to manually
create all these branches and work trees and even then Cloud Code and Codex aren't even sharing
context with each other so it can get chaotic really fast. In Conductor however you can just
open multiple tabs inside the same workspace. So let me just open a new workspace once again just
wait until it's like done and now I have a single tab right and I can choose let's say Opus and say
UltraThink and say research this code base and give me some improvements right and then I can
take this code actually, I can copy the code, open a new tab right here and run the same prompt,
but let's say with GPT-5, let's say, hi, right? And now I have both of these agents do the same
task actually, because in this case, it's a read-only task. They have access to the same
project, the same files, the same workspace. This is truly the closest thing to cursor that I have
seen. So at this point, you're probably asking yourself, what does this all actually cost? This
actually my favorite part because remember I was spending up to $500 a month on cursor and I've
seen screenshots of people hitting $3,000 or more so here's the deal. Conductor itself is completely
free. It's not like cursor where you have to pay for the privilege of using their infrastructure
to actually do anything with AI because Conductor just uses your existing Claude and ChatGPT
subscription. So let's do the math. Because currently I have just two subscriptions. There is
Claude Max 5x for $100 a month and ChatGPT+ for Codex for $20 a month. That's just $120 a month for
a lot of usage. Way more usage than you can get out of the $200 cursor Ultraplan. Plus you get both
model families, no token anxiety, a user interface that is really easy to use, work trees, parallel
agents and everything else that I've just shown you. There's also a bunch of features that I
haven't even touched on yet. There's so much more to go through, not to mention that this team
ships updates all the time. It literally shipped updates over Christmas. Can't make that up.
But let me be fair and also say this, because Cursor still has some pretty high advantages. For
example, Cursor's plan mode is by far genuinely the best in the industry. And I do hope that
Conductor adds something similar that works across the models that they support. There's also no
debug mode and no internal browser. So if you're using these features, then Cursor will still be
your best bet. But truth be told, I haven't used neither one of these features a lot at all. They're
just not part of my daily workflow. But another big potential downside is that Conductor might
take a little bit longer, a few hours or a day or so, to make new models available. I'm currently
talking to them and see exactly how this works. I might be wrong about this but there is definitely
still some work to be done. But in return I get way more tokens and almost everything that I need
from Cursor for my daily work at a fraction of the cost and most importantly no token anxiety and I
know exactly how I pay how much I pay every single month. But knowing about Conductor is just the
first step. I made a full setup tutorial with step-by-step instructions so you can do everything
that I have shown you in this video that you can watch right here.